we'll thanks for joining us why is the
sports world dragging its feet on the
coronavirus you know the obvious answer
I think is money and I know if you look
at what I did several answers I think
obviously money part of it the grab my
South by Southwest Film Festival that
when that was canceled that cause people
a lot of money cost people their jobs
well imagine that what that would happen
in the world of sports how many people
would lose their part-time workers and
full-time workers and never minding the
money to the leaves but lose out it was
it hard to turn the ship around and a
lot of these things people have talked
about well what's a landing gonna do
when they host the Final Four I mean
Elena was awarded that planet for a 2014
he thinks are really kind of long movie
and there's a lot of money to be made
it's hard to turn the ship around but I
also think there's something cultural
about it I actually feel like sports in
particular there is and and in I'm sure
you probably well even anecdotally we
need talk to people in sports there's
this kind of idea they're like oh that's
somewhere else so that's something that
we'll deal with otherwise or that's
something happening in Europe cuz
they're all crammed together or some
other thing or brawn gene kind of talked
about the idea like I'm not going to
play in front of these man and kind of
inherent in his phrasing and that was oh
this is not this is not going to be a
problem for us I think you've cement in
the slowness to you know the best
example this I saw was when the city of
San Francisco announced hey we weren't
there are no more gatherings of more
than 2000 people but the Warriors who of
course have this new stadium right there
in San Francisco did not cancel their
games and no one knows it is going to I
feel like sports still feel like this is
something that's happening somewhere
else
and we'll find out pretty quick whether
or not they're right about and also you
mentioned in your column that you know
when when you're an athlete you fight
through pain you played through pain but
you know illness that that's that's
viewed as weak like we we're not
embracing this because it's it's not an
injury it's it's a you know you have a
sickness here and it's almost like that
Sports mentality of you you fight
through this and you play through this
and you're not going to tell us where we
can't have games and how many people can
show up yeah and I think that's also the
outside nosov it like the reason to me
the best example of how kind of
your sports has got about this is this
new thing that the leaks have done what
they said we're not going to have media
coming into the clubhouse now and I I
feel like that I think it's misguided
from a journalistic aspect or more to
the point it seems that that's not
really what the cancellation of events
are about the issue is not the issue of
not having these games is not worrying
of protecting the players from getting
sick when you have all of these people
in their large it yeah you're good
that's more likely to make those that
are disadvantage to those that are older
those are weaker that's who you're
trying to protect by canceling these
events are having it's not there and it
doesn't feel like athletes don't see it
that way I don't think that we've seen
it that way either this there is this
idea don't like call it listen if I
guide the flu I played through the flu
I've had a migraine and I thought
through that I you know playing through
injuries let alone playing through one
may feel like just the flu to these guys
it doesn't feel like something you
should change your entire life from
doing I mean people play with massive
injuries probably times they shouldn't
play with massive injuries to try to
like fight through it the idea that
because it's not real yet here I mean
it's just kind of reported things it
feels like something that is outside and
the problem is is if you're not making
we're still everyone still playing games
now and so this is actually kind of what
happened in Italy about 10 days ago they
were about where we were now and it
would felt like oh that's happening
somewhere else
and we'll be fine it's just the flu and
they almost joke about it and they
didn't stop some of the gatherings that
have led to some of the issues they've
had now and also I think the NBA being
forward-thinking might be the first
league that says we're gonna hold games
in front of empty arenas or maybe not
hold games I I don't look at the NCAA as
being a trendsetter here with what's
going to happen with March Madness
it might take somebody else to be the
first domino for for that to happen what
do you think yeah I think the NBA would
be first and frankly I do think someone
does it you're going to see these the
dominoes go pretty quick and I think
that's another reason that you're you're
seeing people so hesitant to do it
because once once the NBA and I agree
with you there will be the NBA if the
NBA says no or cancel games or we're not
in front of fan then it you can no
longer then it's making a decision not
to do it at that point like right now
collectively we can all kind of things I
found it telling and all those who came
out with that press release together
they're trying to say hey listen we're
all on the same page here so no one's
stepping out on the limb I think no one
wants to do that but once someone steps
out and it will be hard for the NHL to
justify Oh to me
maybe the entablature minute isn't
canceled but the nit will be and like
some of those like non-essential and I
think that's where you'll see once
someone makes that first step forward
I think the dominoes will fall pretty
fast well thanks for joining us we
appreciate your time of course as always
sir thank you
that's a we'll each columnist New York
Magazine contributing editor